today we're going to talk about
intermediate moves internet sells in
between moves and ocean books all four
of them all the same thing and as I just
said that means that it's very important
now this is my very last lesson at the
Chess Club in fact it's like one of my
last hours at the Chess Club I'm going
to be heading back to Philadelphia
tomorrow I've had a great time and this
is my last lesson here for advanced for
intermediate level players today I want
to talk about in between moves partly
because it's such an important tactic
especially for the advanced level
usually once you're a master level
player you don't miss or expert level
player you don't miss things like double
attacks and pins is often because
they're so ingrained but it seems that
somehow in between moves are something
that even really high level players miss
a lot so it's really considered the the
tactic that you need to improve at all
levels why do you think it is that
people miss in between moves so often or
intermediate moves so often yes
initial thing is drawing the attention
yeah I mean it just I think it's just a
bias that people have in their thinking
you know they want to they want to play
relatively quickly and a lot of times
it's you're looking few few moves ahead
in the variation and therefore you're
trying you're kind of just missing like
little possibilities that come along the
way of course for people who are for
computers for instance it's like they
don't even think of it in between mows
it's just a totally human concept right
so that's kind of what you want to train
yourself to do - instead of like be
thinking automatically they're queens
intake must take Queen you're thinking a
little bit beyond that and really
checking all of your possibilities so in
this this of course a very simple
example of an in-between move you play
Queen da check before taking on f7
and the final point is that if the Queen
were to black white would just be able
to play simple pin rook FA right so
usually in chess at a higher level
there's many tactics kind of combining
together rather than just one working
and its own it's somebody any question
about that so I wanted to go over some
cool examples of it and also one thing
I've been doing with some of my
beginners classes that I thought I'd
tried it with you just for fun is I show
an example of a tactic and we talk about
for the class like double attack or pin
and then I ask somebody to create in a
cool example of that theme from scratch
on the demo board just like kind of come
up with it from scratch so if anybody
want to try that with Intermezzo z--
please be my guest
any volunteers Z's maybe no leave the
hard drive anybody want to try it could
be something like famous that you're
trying to recall or you could just make
it up
all right we'll think about it and
hopefully you will change your mind and
decide to try it
all right so I just want to show a
couple really simple examples for so we
can look at like some very typical
themes for instance in this move what is
why play well yeah that would be the
movement you'd probably be looking at
like five moves in advance just like
simple work capture but then what would
black play so if you were to play a rook
takes rock what would black play
so black head is a two bishops for a
rock what would Black's best move be and
I'll play that if white were to play
work takes rock what would blacks bass
move be so that's the first question
you could play e3 but then I could
revert to the move that I think white
should play anyway and I think you will
be in some trouble
well yeah but we're asking late after
work takes work what's your black flat
what about your black play
but either he's a good question actually
I think it's kind of a cool answer but
I'll show too after that but what's your
black play after work takes are up no
and we're cafe wouldn't work very well
because then we could take in Queen this
should be three we can play work to eat
eight check and then take take the work
on a eight and then we're going to be
cleaning next move Bishop g5 working a
check and again we're going to take on a
eight and then we're just up we have two
works for two bishops so and plus we're
playing da Queen so we have plenty of
time to just sacrifice from the e upon
it's funny because this moves like
really not that difficult but it's I
think there's like some kind of vision
problem just because normally in chess
you're looking for at acne moves
sometimes it's almost harder to see good
defensive moves even though in a way
they should be as easy to find basically
whites threatening Ricky eight Jack
right so how do you stop it it's not
very many ways because work the eight
doesn't help
could you play working a check anyway so
there's there's really only one move for
K 7 doesn't really help either because
you know yes exactly right so if I play
rook takes rook here seems like a good
move you know you're threatening working
a check it seems very difficult to stop
rook f8 doesn't work because we capture
work d8 doesn't work because we play
rook e8 anyway but if you play Bishop b5
here it's actually pretty tricky right
because that prevents rook e8
somehow the bishop is x-raying and it's
kind of onion and unusual especially a
bit of an unusual defensive maneuver
normally you don't see the bishop doing
that and now in this particular
variation black would be doing pretty
well right we have two bishops for work
plus upon
what wouldn't have to go for this of
course but you know that would be kind
of a blunder but in this position blacks
doing okay this point on d7 is really
strong but black has the two bishops and
it's preventing immediate disaster right
now I think your move your the other
move you got you mentioned III white
would play wiki a check so you can't
take because of Queen and if you now
play King g7 what do you think what you
should do here well if we're takes a8
I'll play you takes F 2 and then I'm
turning the Queen and checkmate so
that's a bit annoying well if you play
work III then Bishop just takes back
so what is the best move for right here
work situ and then your ideas if e to
you're just going to play you're going
to play work takes bishop or something
so no we're c2 so you're saying if works
you to I can't really play YouTube
because you can play just you can play
just our rook takes c4 and then if Queen
I capture and if work takes EA takes it
takes a yeah that should work out pretty
well yeah I was also thinking that you
could probably play here
because now Bishop takes it's also looks
good but this you know this could still
result in some complications because of
that and no no and it's not completely
clear and it's I say you know white at
White has a rook for a bishop and upon
but it's not it's not a clear what's
going to happen at all yeah yeah that's
true so you could play where he ate
first and now you're threatening work
takes III which would be very
devastating but now if we play here
not so it's kind of it looks like it's
basically transposing to the same thing
yeah so I think your move works you two
is better but anyway after after work
takes F to Bishop b5 is the best move
right so what you white do instead
should be pretty obvious by now instead
of playing work takes rope you just play
what first yeah I just play work to e8
check first and now when the King goes
to g7 now when you take the rook there's
no time to play Bishop b5 because we can
just take on AAA right so or queen yeah
we can take any game yeah so pretty
simple example but in you know important
and this is also comes out under the
same theme of move order a lot of times
whenever you see a tactic and it doesn't
quite work you also have to look at
alternate move orders so in between move
is often related to looking at different
move orders now
what you do here is why it
he don't call out if you play Knight a5
Bishop takes Queen it's kind of in the
wing right yeah
Bishop III that's an excellent
in-between move and now you're also this
is really a lot of different tactics yes
the main tactic is discovery but then
the main point is that after rook takes
Queen instead of recapturing the rook we
have the in-between move Bishop takes
Queen with check and then after
capturing the Rock White is going to be
up material so so it's just a simple one
just try to get your tactics working and
now how about your weight to move so
your Queen on e4 is in take
diamond
yeah Bishop takes before excellent and
now the idea is that if you play rook
takes Queen
we have rook takes Queen and you don't
have time to recapture this Bishop one
before and let yourself some material
because there's a back rank mate
right so again a combination of themes
that are at work here it's also a bunch
of themes it's in between move it's
discovered attack and it's back rank
right and the other main point of Bishop
takes pawn is that this queen is
Guardian c2 so you don't really have
time to do anything better finally we
should probably look at well what if
black just plays Queen to d7 with the
idea that now your queen and your bishop
is in take now what you can play just
like you can just play watch mm what
right Queen takes d5 exactly so another
distraction and back rang so it just
seems like in some of these positions
every single tactical theme that you've
ever looked at is is coming up which is
to both tactical teams are always
combining rather than in books where you
know they might be showing you focusing
on one or the other this is your game
this is a really cool line so this is
white to move
so you see there are some potential pins
here but how do you take advantage of it
right because you can't really put more
pressure on this f5 [ __ ] up because
rook g5 is guarded by the pawn on H X so
when you have a pin piece one thing you
want to do is continue to attack the
piece the other thing you can do if you
can't do that is try to remove the pin
piece is defenders in some way and for
the kids class we did a lesson on pins
and which Zeid answered every single
question he was like five hundred points
higher rated than everyone in the class
when and it showed
kind of like when Grand Master Ben
Feingold was here and he got every
question in tonight yes so if Ricky won
and then if work takes rock well you
take the bishop with check then say I
play your work takes rook rook takes
Bishop
yeah and then I can move my rock to h1
or something
so that you don't even win upon in the
end right well I guess no you don't
really want to pawn yeah but that's
that's close so after Ricky one work
takes you on you tried Bishop takes fi
check which isn't in between move but
unfortunately for you your opponent can
Reese AK rifice there and play rook
takes Bishop so what other ideas do you
have diamond well I think that's but
that's kind of that's kind of the same
thing oh you mean immediately what you
do it immediately I just recaptured with
the rook and there's no pin and I mean
Idol rook I could take with actually it
doesn't really matter they both seem
adequate take with or hit play rook
takes a five and you don't seem to have
any follow up there
in fact mm-hmm
brick g4 it's true that your bishop can
take the rook but other than that you
don't really have a threat right so you
can't really take advantage of a pin
just by putting a piece and a square
that the opponent can't take it right
you have to also go for the attack yes
Justin Julian or rather what's it
exactly right so it's all about the move
order so after Ricky won rook takes you
on instead of taking with the bishop on
fi you take with the rook right and then
if the recaptures you have Bishop takes
f5 check the King moves and after King
takes you won you're up what you're up
you're up a bishop exactly right so
again it's an important oops that's a
bad move so again it's important thing
where in between moves are often related
to move order you know you have to look
at all the possible move orders in a
position and all the different
possibilities of captures and jacks
right so instead of playing Bishop takes
a five plain book takes a five here and
now black is in a lot of trouble
and if he tries to retreat his rook or
something like that you can just play
rook takes discover check and that's
even worse yeah
so basically resigns now this one is
actually really I just wanted to show
you this one before we get into some
some that require a little bit more
calculation because I think it's a
really great illustration of how tactics
and strategy interplay in chess a lot of
people talk about whether somebody is a
tactical or a strategic player while the
reality is that all good players are
good at both tactics and strategy right
good players are good at knowing where
to put their pieces and are also good at
analyzing checkmates and variations
right now in this instance white is
slightly worse well actually more than
slightly worse white is definitely worse
partly because we're data pond secondly
because this knight on d4 is a very good
minor piece right there's a saying that
kind of like in a principle that if the
bishops are generally better than
knights but when there are pawns only on
one side of the board that the Knights
raise in value a lot because one of the
assets of the bishop is that akin you
know slice across the board and attack
both sides which matters less when there
are pawns on only one side of the board
right so black is definitely better here
and moreover Black's attacking White's
queen right now so in this situation
what do you think White's best play is
to try to get the most defensible
position possible because we're not
going to get a better position here
oops
and come up with a variation not just a
move if you can
and obviously has something to do with
in between Moe's
well okay if you play Queen a for I mean
I could take one f3 and then what do you
want to do it out okay would you want to
you could okay so yeah Queen a for
worst-case scenario black just takes on
f3 and it looks like a very good
position
yeah
you if night takes and Queen takes
Knight
no you were thinking well yeah that's
the problem right okay so yeah we should
look at that so if Queen a three-night
takes half three Queen takes f3
now if Burke takes me one Queen takes
you one and everything is okay right but
instead black has this in between move
Queen takes Queen right and now we can't
we can't play rook takes d6 because the
Queen just moves away and we're down a
trick for a queen and if we recapture or
down a rock right so that's bad
well you can play Queen a-one and not
lose a rook but again we could play a
night ace f3 and and just like a worst
case scenario we could well I think
though that if black wants to try to
press an advantage here what do you
prefer to be in a rock n game or a queen
and game if you want to try to just like
play for a million moves yeah you want
to play for the Queen onion because the
rock n game will be more clearly drawn
right so if your opponent plays Queen a1
and you can't find anything better after
Knight takes f3 pawn f3 then trading
into an even more simplified endgame
right because if Queen takes f3 there's
work takes d6 so if you figure you have
to trade something off here then you
would rather trade off rooks then trade
off Queens right because if you trade
off Queens it should be much easier for
white to draw then if you trade off the
rocks right that's just a general
principle which most people like to go
by as working games are always drawn but
how can we do a little bit better than
that because that actually turns out to
be like after Queen f1 it's the same
thing right after Knight f3 you you
can't take with the Queen because of
Queen takes f3 and then we lose so we
have to take back with the pawn and now
if black ones to black and just play
rook takes d1 Queen do you wan and it's
absolutely transposed right so how can
we do a little bit better than that as
y8 if we want to have a little bit of an
easier time of possibly defending this
position
okay so if we go queen eight check and
then our opponent goes King h7 or worth
it there's a couple things that black
and try black and try a king h7 black
and try Rafi a it but well queen CA
check now if they try King h7 what can
you do right and then were your
perpetual if they try to go back with
the king which would be something that
you would want
so Queen chx a bit more forcing because
then they pretty much they want to try
to get the most out of this position
they pretty much have to play work to be
8 and then what's what's the difference
so then after idea you obviously have to
move your queen
so where would you move your queen to
right well you could play queen g4 and
then one and then black would play what
try to visualize that in your head right
so he takes with a knight with check and
then you play what and then how is that
different than the variations that we
were looking at is it exactly the same
or is there a key difference right so
can your opponent plank can't play Queen
takes Queen right if they play Queen
takes Queen then you have worked a c8
exactly so if once you play Queen c8
after work the a queen g4 and Knight f3
now you can get away with taking with a
queen because if the Queen captures now
you have rook takes d8 check in between
moves and you end up winning right so
instead they want to won't be able to do
that so after Knight takes f3 Queen
takes f3 instead they're just going to
have to acquiesce something like rook
takes d1 Queen takes d1 and now with the
same position but instead of having the
pawn on f3 you have them connected right
so it's extremely minor I mean compared
to a lot of things that we're looking at
it's not a difference of a pawn or a
rock or a checkmate it's just a
difference of a position that's slightly
easier to defend but I wanted to point
this out because a lot of people say
that strategy is not that important
because under games of players under
1,800 or so
tactics always decides the game well
that can be true and strategy can still
be important right it's not like they're
mutually exclusive and the reason is
because there are more tactics that are
liable to come up in your name for you
to win pieces and check me if you have
good strategy and the opposite is true
also if you're really good tactically
but you're not good at like placing your
pieces and your pawns you're going to
give your opponent a lot of
is right and this is just one example of
how the two interplay in a pretty subtle
way so now let's go look at some more
more violent ones now and this is a
subject subcategory of in between moves
which has a very romantic name and it's
white to move so just try to analyze it
into its logical conclusion weight to
move
and you go analyze it to its logical
conclusion ah
I think he has okay okay so a queen
takes f6 what do you think blacks best
move is
exactly very good okay so Queen takes f6
and now this is a now it's blacks move
so if black plays G takes f6 now white
just has what somebody else just worked
you for and whites up a piece right so I
can't do that so instead we have a
subcategory of in between move which is
called does anybody know what it's
called when you are going to lose a
piece so you try to grab whatever you
can for it yes desperado that's a really
common tactic that you see you when
pieces go flying and it usually involves
the plane so after Queen takes f6
instead of G takes f6 black would
probably want to try Queen takes e4 but
now White has the counter desperado well
if we play Bishop takes to e4 then pawn
takes f6 and b7 or create Bishop c6
doesn't lead to anything because we can
just recapture the pawn right so instead
and Julie already mentioned it but
somebody else might want to mention it
as well yeah exactly so now you have
this counter or desperado Queen takes f7
if the rook captures again in between
move instead of taking the the Queen we
take the rook and now after and then
we're up a bishop exactly so and why it
is a pawn takes f7 not work instead
diamon what were you gonna say right so
if tha now so you didn't have to take on
f7 like if you took on f7 then we would
have we could always play Queen takes f7
and Bishop takes Queen just like before
but if you play King h8 then our Queen's
intake and you don't have any clear
answer if we play Queen b6 trying to
attack the rook and the Queen at once
black could play what hmm
queen that you won check and that after
king h2
boy four takes point I have Queen da
check so what would you do here is black
why is this not a cook as we call it
Queen - where will Queen - ate the
bishops on that diagonal remembers
always it's so funny how you guys are so
good at finding moves that win for you
but you're not as good at finding moves
that defend for you I think it's really
interesting and it's like kind of
indicative of I guess the way most
people are in chess they're much better
at finding moves that like sacrifices
for themselves rather than anticipating
sacrifices for their opponent I bet I
bet everybody's like 300 points lower
rated on average at looking at finding
sacks for their opponent so then kind of
have to bring it up a little
yes blacks move how to black get out of
this because our Queens intake or works
intake Queenie one check King h2 it's
like not so clear what to do yeah
exactly very good as usual getting the
Queen into the defense is the key right
it's so important to get the Queen into
defense in chess and I think it's a
really underrated thing because you know
we talked about getting the Queen into a
attack but getting into the defense is
equally important and now yeah if only Y
you could play Bishop here and then
Bishop there would be a nice little
study like ending but you don't get to
move twice in chess so like I could play
any number of things here and work f8 or
d6
so yeah the desperado is kind of like a
sub-genre or like a sub variation of the
in-between move and it really comes up a
lot and the more names you have for
things the better because I feel like it
becomes easier to see things when you
have more names for them this one is
black to move so try to find the winning
variation for black because there's a
lot of different there's all the
instruments anybody doesn't have the
answer but swipes to move so this is
black to moving to try to get the move
over right in here we guys here move
order is really important give yourself
a minute
you see better from there receive
anybody ready to set up or in between
move on the devil word since you already
have a diamond you want to try to set up
on there what would you want to answer
this question okay
okay if you play more see one check what
are my possible replies and that would
be pretty nasty for me but instead of
after work see one check what can I do
besides Bishop to be 1 and the other
moves I might be able to play what's
that why do I can play can be 2 right
because if you play work takes d1 again
we have what again we have Queen tastes
h7 checkmate so it's good to notice that
right away because it comes up in
variations right so if we see one check
immediately King b2 and then you know
you can play Queen f6 check and I play
King a3 but it's not clear where the
mate is and again if you take on d1 it's
still made on H of n right
or were t7 just passively depending on
some 8 well we would just play queenie 8
check and queenie 5 or yeah i mean that
looks like it just winds right away you
could play Queen f6 but then we have
yeah I mean we're just we're just
winning because we're up a piece also
yeah what we're saying hmm so if Queen
Essex check right away and then we play
Kingdom you won so now it looks like
you've lost your chance to play Roxy one
check well if Queen D for though we have
Queen takes d4 check
tactics how many people have done tactic
since last week
tactics trainer ah tactics books good
really are you sure all right so look at
all the different move orders think
about all the things you're trying to do
and look at the different move orders
because that's how you get these
problems and you got to do everything
forcing right forcing moves is really
important and Jess you got to look at
all the captors it checks all the
checkmate threats in this case checkmate
threats not going to be enough because
queen h7 is just made right away
right but sometimes it's not the first
movement you're seeing a lot of times
especially with stronger players like
you guys it's like it's not the first
move you don't see it's the move after
the first move that you know you're not
looking at enough possibilities people
are usually sharpest in the position
right in front of themselves right and
that's why a lot of times I mean how
many people have you had the experience
where you make a move and as soon as you
take your hand off the piece you realize
what you've done wrong like everybody's
had that experience right yeah and
that's because you just see things
better when they're right in front of
you I mean there's very few people who
are better at blindfold test and they
are a regular chess I don't do any of
you know anyone who's better at
blindfold than they aren't regular I
mean diamond you are huh who Paul Morphy
huh why not my mom vine pick okay you
know Karen often I think they're the
same actually it's exactly the same yeah
it's true
though the same with a blind Porter
without a blind fall
edit edit this out this is a really
emerges alright yeah so it waits out
well queen of seven defends against a
mate but here you're down a piece so you
need to you need to like really do
something spectacular or you're not
going to you're not going to save this
game you're going to lose it's true and
if you were up a rope but the thing is
if you are like up or work in this
position you could play moves like rook
Queen f7 and if you're not getting mated
and then hallelujah are going to win the
game but here you're going to lose the
game if you don't have something though
that is spectacular and wins right away
so if you play Queen s6 check then King
b1 what else can you try there so far we
haven't tried anything in that position
except okay wow that doesn't look like
it's very good right let's go
well Queen c6 is not check visa allows
made on h7 again okay so it was so if
work c1 were take see you on then why
not seize everybody tried to visualize
that position I swear that if I put this
position on the board everybody would
get the answer yes well if pawn takes
work Queen than just king takes and you
know you're on the May Queen f6 check
King b1 but if you play the work down
first that's what other people tried but
then it works you want check first what
does white play no no no no what it's
white play after works new on jackal
yeah QB 2 if it works you want check we
play King V 2 but that's not so clear
after King a3 I mean you don't what do
you do then
oh you don't have a maid right you let
me out of the cage so instead after a
Queen f6 check immediately King b1 work
c1 check work take c1 anybody else see
the move there I know that Justin
already called it out anyone else
Dimon do you see what will black to do
there so try to visualize it Queen f6
check King b1 rook c1 check and then
after work take c1 black plays why this
is where you got to look at all the
different captures and chaps and move
orders so instead of takes on c1 king c1
queen a1 check you start with XIV Queen
a1 check and then after King a1 and what
do you want to make know what wait why
not why not rug why hey thanks getting
that good the queen is good you need to
make a queen there all right so let's
just go over that fast so this is like a
perfect move order position because from
the very beginning you know all the
different moves that will lead to mate
but and it's kind of easy to see those
but to get the right order is very
tricky so if your Queen f6 Kim v1 work
c1 check immediately is the key here and
then after work takes you on pawn takes
you want fall short because King c1
queen a1 check and there's no mate right
so instead you play queen a1 check
well not mate but it's a it's a perp
yeah we got the Queen's t3 mate it's not
me yet it's not the mate but we've got
this mate right so this is a really
pretty maid also isn't it
what's that well yeah we're telling you
promote anything except for a queen you
lose so so it's a pretty difficult
problem it's it seems easy at first
because there's just not that many
different possibilities for black but
you really have to get it in exactly the
precise order right which one is hard to
see Queen a one Jack right yeah so this
one is white to move and it's actually
from our Fischer damn sure white yeah
Wow
well if I please clean 2d6 we just take
one d3 and do the material account I
mean you've got this pawn on s6 but
you're going to be down a piece yes
this one's really weird I know this is a
very very strange position and I'll give
you a little bit of a hint here because
you know I want somebody to try to find
it but I talked about actually combining
different themes and this is a theme
that combines in between moves and traps
you think you have it already good look
let's hold up
this is just like a really weird one
very very strange
you already you have in the back
and you say you think you have it -
Justin okay I'll give you another minute
then I don't know you probably saw it
like from the beginning of the game
you want try to give them a hand no it's
not quite a train do a piece that can
usually be very powerful in fact it
could be the most powerful piece gets
trapped in a very strange place good
hint so that's the weird thing about
Queens getting draft right you don't
expect the Queen to really get trapped
because it's such a powerful piece that
you would think it has a lot of
different ways to get out I'm surprised
this isn't yeah obviously the date
obviously the pitcher was not playing
this game from heaven the state is zom
the date that I Anna - Han
not the date that he played in
I hadn't even seen this game before
so Justin what do you think no that's
not it
okay what do you think that's absolutely
incredible so upon takes then and then
you can just play Bishop f4 right but if
if Queen takes g3 not Bishop f4
immediately because then you would end
up after you would end up you know just
even in down even in material yeah like
so instead it just work takes d4 and now
wherever the Queen goes next move you
play exactly and you're going to end up
with a crushing position in a beautiful
last six pawn right and there's no room
for Desperados because but black needs
to get the bishop back right so if we
try to desperado white will actually end
up in an even better position up a whole
bishop right so black would have to try
something like Queen to b6 or Queen to
d7 or Queen a5 and then after Bishop to
f4 you know the only possibility is now
to play Queen takes off for work data
for and of course it's not as
spectacular in some of our positions in
that White's not why still has some work
to do but obviously a very strong
position right but it was very strange
tactic great whenever at least you know
anything like the Queen can't go
anywhere it can't backtrack this way
because of the g6 pawn
can't go to h4 anywhere on this diagonal
allows Bishop f4 check and yeah Queen
takes d3 is also possible but and then
if we saw our bishops of opposite color
but still you know white is obviously
say hard here with yes I think I'm
pretty sure yeah I actually only have
the analogy right yeah I get what's that
Weber
I don't even know for the water somebody
haven't heard of so yeah what's that I
think he did do queen taste III I so to
look it up
but it's just such a outstanding
combination I really it's very nice so
yeah anyway you can see that in between
moves can range from really high level
stuff to very simple things earlier in
the game and you know beginners can miss
them but they can also really just be in
pretty much any variation you need to
always look at the different move orders
and the different captures and checks
and of course it's a very human concept
in between moves and in termessos
because people are thinking in a certain
way they're often thinking of recaptures
and that's the bias that sometimes
allows these in between moves to slip
through